[Music]
fermius Magneton luggage for me my range
is the most normal thing in the world I
can't imagine singing tenor or bass
baritone That's not me it certainly
isn't Maps emanuel chen chat his voice
is an octave higher than the average
male voice and metaphorically - he seems
to float in a higher realm it's not easy
to keep pace with him through the
winding dark passages backstage in
Berlin's Schiller theater since it
glides away as single-mindedly and agile
as only someone who has spent his whole
life in the theatre can be really did
grow up in the theatre literally I used
to refuse to go to nursery so my parents
simply took me with them to the theatre
they didn't know what else to do with me
[Music]
the son of a conductor and a singer he
watched everything and imitated
everything he was barely 6 years old
when he made his first television
appearance
[Music]
since his debut as queen of the night in
Mozart's Magic Flute
Maxo Manuel Sanchez has performed on the
opera stage countless times he says he
always feels stage fright before a
performance today is no exception even
though the atmosphere backstage here in
Berlin suggests one big happy family
even the great Jurgen Flynn the operas
artistic director personally wishes him
luck before the performance he's cold
love is stronger than death that's the
initial premise of the Orpheus myth and
the Opera that Christoph Willibald Gluck
made based on it director Jurgen flim
turns that theme into a question is love
really stronger than death
[Music]
this concept toy I thought the concept
was great the fact that Eurydice does
not really rise from the dead that there
is no happy ending it's actually all
just a delirious hallucination at her
grave font OD dick is in this role sin
Church can give free rein to his acting
Verve and celebrate every desperate
nuance as a director - like here in
karlsruhe centage displays his great
sensitivity for the theatrical when he
discovers what sounds like cries of
pleasure in an aria by george frideric
handel if he wants to bring that to life
[Music]
[Music]
finish fights Isaiah worked way it was
very good work for me to work as a
director myself for us because it makes
you appreciate what a director actually
dance
despite his modesty sandwich certainly
knows what he's doing and he believes in
the value of hard work both as a
director and a singer in the last 10 or
15 years I've focused on balance too
much perfectionism is self-destructive
but so is too little it's always a
question of balance
[Music]
max Emanuel centric singer director
theater man for all seasons his Berlin
debut was a triumph here Aida scene
might not have come back from the dead
but it wasn't because of any flaw in
sensitive voice
[Music]
you
[Music]